But my point is that we buy insurance
to protect ourselves financially
in case those things happen, right?
So by investing sustainably
we're doing two things.
We're creating insurance,
reducing the risk to our planet and to our economy,
and at the same time, in the short term,
we're not sacrificing performance.
[Man in comic: "What if it's a big hoax and we create a better world for nothing?"]
Good, you like it. I like it too.
(Laughter)
I like it because it pokes fun
at both sides of the climate change issue.
I bet you can't guess which side I'm on.
But what I really like about it
is that it reminds me of something Mark Twain said,
which is, "Plan for the future,
because that's where you're going to spend
the rest of your life."
Thank you.
(Applause)